hey guys this is dennis the founder of
think care and i'm david griffin
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of the fourth
episode of uh agents of shield uh what's
it called again i spy i spy
my little eye
so it's another it's another one of the
case of the week yeah you know freak of
the week monster of the week every you
know there's always like you know
buffy had it when it first started
smallville had it when it first started
uh fringe had it when it first started
and now agents of shield is doing that
where every single episode is is its own
like
enclosed story right which can be good
it can be fine if i care about the
characters i'm still struggling to buy
into the show because
i don't i don't really care about
anything that the characters are going
through fringe had john noble and john
knows performance from the very first
episode is incredible he's an amazing
these actors i mean you know clark craig
is awesome i mean you know his agent
coulson he's great but i don't have a
character i can buy into yet that's the
one struggle i'm having with this i need
a character that i want to care about
i'm not sure if there's one yet i think
characters plus there needs to be a
deeper or overarching storyline right
not drama doesn't mean you know like you
know because we like josh he does all
the comedy and drama at the same time no
does not be deep but just
just something to buy into besides the
like you said the mystery of the week
well yeah the only
long-term storyline that's going on is
about agent coulson's death and whether
or not you know
you know is he vision is he a robot is
he a clone is he you know what happened
to him right that's kind of like the
only thing plus maybe this rising tide
stuff which really hasn't panned out at
all that that sky may be
you know
trying to infiltrate shield yeah i mean
there's something they're they're
building to something you know they just
got picked up a little week or two ago
for you know full 22 episodes or however
many they're gonna go which is you know
we'll see how that goes but you know so
it is going but it's like
and again everybody a lot of people when
you talk can you talk a little bit
negatively about the show a lot of
people say immediately like well be
patient like something's gonna happen
you're like you know it's building to
something i'm like yeah but i don't
really like that excuse because i mean
you and i both big fans of boardwalk
empire that's a slow-moving show that's
a lot of dialogue not a lot of action
sometimes there's a whole episode really
nothing but dialogue going on i love
that show because i'm interested in the
characters i want to know more about
them so shield i think and i know it's
early so i'm not i'm giving it time i'm
not going to drop the show with them
it's only the fourth episode fourth
episode it's early but and i want to see
i want to see more character development
i mean fitz simmons banter back and
forth can only last but so long it's not
going to be funny in episode 22. so like
i just want a little more character
development yeah i i'm thinking maybe
towards the end of the season or
something let's talk about this episode
you know you have this this whole story
of this old agent that that went rogue
or they thought went rogue or they
thought it was dead right and then they
find out that she's been taken over by
somebody and see that may be something
that that may lead to a bigger storyline
who's that somebody last week with the
whole black orb thing and the hand
coming out i mean that might come you
know it's all yeah right who knows you
know because my roommate the whole time
i was watching he's like hydra hydra you
know like hydra hopefully it's something
like that an organization like that you
got aim and iron man three maybe yeah
something that that that fans know about
that they can tie in a lot of these
things because right now it just seems
like one-off stuff and right not that
interested someone that had mentioned in
the comments or or maybe it was on
facebook to us and i thought it was very
um very fitting for why the show isn't
connecting as well is that
that there's no sense of danger for the
characters
you don't really feel like oh man
they're gonna die or they're getting
hurt or anything like that it just
you know it just feels like bam bam bam
you know like with the action sequences
right i mean you have to have something
that's like at stake it doesn't have to
be world ending but it has to be even if
it's just for the character's safety
again yeah they haven't yeah i don't
you're not sure what the stakes are and
you also don't even see the fear in any
of the characters eyes like you don't
see like oh man i'm gonna die you know
right yeah everyone kind of plays it too
cool for school like imagine if you were
you know sky as like you just
got into the secret organization
wouldn't you be freaked out about like
everything yeah would you be paranoid
about like every mission that you go on
i mean i think the best character in
this in this app this week's episode and
i spy was um the uh you know the mystery
of the week the uh
the young lady with the you know who's
been controlled her whole life she was a
good character she was probably one of
the better uh guest stars they've had so
far this season she was interesting she
had a backstory i liked her and
coulson's dialogue like and coulson's in
that interrogation room trying to get
information out of her that was those
are some great scenes i thought she i i
hope i mean she's not dead so i hope
that she comes back i know she has to go
on trial or something but i hope they
bring her back i liked her she that's an
interesting character she was a very
interesting character she actually stood
apart from everybody else not for some
obvious reasons but just because she's
just she was dynamic i thought she was
interesting and then you even saw may
kind of be a little jealous yeah i have
agent coulson's relationship with with
her because like
she knows she's just amazed like oh i'm
the badass one that's also cool seeing
with them in the hotel room and she's
like you know colson feels bad for you i
don't you know so yeah that's good
that's good
yeah so you know i'm not going to give
up on the show yet i'm still going to
keep going with it it's it's not like
i'm i think the show's terrible or
anything i just i just think that it's
right now it's it's just kind of run of
the mill you know like nothing
nothing we haven't seen before but yeah
but i i put my faith in joss whedon and
and uh you know uh his brother jed
weeded and sparked
yeah yeah
yeah so i'm thinking that towards the
end of the season we're gonna start
seeing much better character development
and uh much much better story lines
right yeah i hope it's good i mean this
is it's got the potential to have huge
stories has the potential to have it's
got great action already i like the way
it's shot it doesn't look cheap i mean
you know for network it looks really
good so yeah i mean i i hope it i wanted
to get a little bit better i'm not fully
invested in it but i'm not giving up on
it either okay yeah all right guys so
let us know what you think are you still
watching it or
or have you given up already um you can
post your comments below on the website
thinkhero.com or on our youtube channel
that's thinkheropro and make sure you
subscribe to that as well well we're
also on twitter uh all of us here at
think hero of course at think hero
personally i'm at griffinde and we have
a facebook page that's uh facebook.com
think hero fans and click the like
button
you